why their mind not happy what's wrong
with the women with me you know why
should I not be happy I'm a human being
this is you know I'm alive now people
who are in a starvation famine in
Somalia or sometimes you know obviously
that's really difficult although the Red
Cross gets there somebody gets there
soon but some for some is too late so
obviously you can't reach those people
and yet with such a question you want to
reach them with food before you expect
them to think about anything and you
know because they're but even although
strangely I think actually if you're
starving to death you reach a kind of
point where you're kind of high on the
starvation and you know of course if
your children are going that's really
agonizing it's terrible it is terrible
so I don't mean just blithely say you
can go with someone whose leg was just
blown off or whatever and you do that we
have to help fix them up first of course
but then once people are at a modicum
which most of the people are you know
four-fifths of humanity or I'd have some
sort of modicum then that's the question
and you get them and you ask them that
question and then you try to help them
see the half full of the glass or maybe
the quarter for the third row in some
cases most of all too many cases
nowadays I'm sad to say but that's the
question to ask them and all of their
traditions and if there's any
traditional religion that they have that
tells them that they're supposed to not
be happy it's a misunderstanding like
many buddhist thing well Buddha says
you're going to suffer so I'm supposed
to suffer that's not correct the Buddha
said that you will suffer if you persist
in being stupid if you persist in being
ignorant and egotistical you can easily
overcome that by being more intelligent
and more altruistic and be more cheerful
and you don't have to do it you know
that that was just a symptom diagnosis
of the symptom of the ignorance you know
it wasn't like what you have to be on
the contrary he said you can enjoy life
like Nirvana if you wake up so I think
all the traditions kind of say that you
know if
who raised Jesus then you'll be happy if
you dance with Krishna you'll be happy
you know if you venerate the prophet and
surrender to the prophet you'll be happy
you know they all do not just buying the
sky later and now some bad priests in
some bad institutions might say well
yeah only when you get to heaven and you
have to suffer and be my slave those are
misinterpretation